we're bringing you some breaking news
out of Gaza and a fire in a residential
building has killed 21 people let's
speak to him that Sayed she's joining us
on the line from Gaza what are you
hearing about this fire that broke out
in the jabalia refugee camp
yes so according to local sources uh in
the same neighborhood of where this
residential building where the fire
erupted in this Residential Building
they said that the family was actually
having a birthday party and there was a
gas leak in the home where uh the the
the people where where the family was
and a lot of visitors with guests were
in that party as well uh when the kind
when the candles uh were uh were lit and
that's when the fire quickly erupted and
uh big explosions happened in the home
it's a residential building so
um more the the fire actually not just
that apartment but
um it grew to outside the the windows
and outside the balcony of that home uh
going to the next apartment as well
until now 21 people uh were taken to
hospitals uh completely burned and dead
there is a number doesn't have been
injured we still don't know the number
the exact number of injuries uh the
Ministry of Health said that numbers
have arrived to Indonesian Hospital in
the North End of Gaza Strip and uh until
now uh like recently just a while ago
the civil defense was still trying to
control the fire they were still trying
to put off or put down the fire they
have succeeded in doing that but until
now they have not been able to know the
exact number of the people who have been
lost or um killed by this uh incident
right so we do expect perhaps on the
death toll to rise then so far we're
hearing as you're saying 21 people and
that includes uh women and children you
know
yes women children men and and a number
of people are still not identified where
they are whether they're in the injuries
or among those who have been killed
unfortunately even the bodies that were
taken to to the hospital they were
burned and that's why there's there is
now a little bit of a problem in
identifying exactly who these bodies are
for
tell us once again the waiting for the
for the final results by uh the Ministry
of Health okay and for anyone just
joining us on Al Jazeera just remind us
once again what you're learning about
the cause of this fire in in jabalia
the fire when the Kindles were being
lighted for a birthday party so uh it
the the main according to local sources
the main reason is that it's a gas leak
give us a sense of that particular area
in Gaza and
um Gaza as we know is quite densely
populated uh just talk us through that
particular area
now first of all we're saying uh debalia
Refugee Council when we're talking about
refugee camps in the outside news that
we're talking about very densely
populated areas uh the buildings are
very very much attached to one another
uh and that's why and that's why usually
when there is uh
uh fire like this when there is an
airstrike when there is anything then
the the casualties or the destruction is
not only in that area or that part it
goes or spreads quickly to the parts
that are around that area and that's why
there's always a massive destruction
when there is any casual when there is
any incident going on in any um a camp
like that also the civil defense here do
not have the strong and uh um lots of
capabilities to actually control it took
them a long while to be able to put off
the fire to be able to reach to uh to
the building to to put down the fire uh
to save the people from from around that
building even and from the building uh
we we know that it's a three-story
building and the fire was in the third
story uh uh in the third or but the the
fire was going down
deeply until the first floor and that's
why it was very difficult
excuse me it was very difficult for the
civil defense to reach with their
capabilities and put off the fire
quickly all right Tim now we'll let you
go for an hour you'll keep us across the
story thank you so much is our
correspondent from Gaza